each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
well we'll make a start now for the
second part of the talk I'm choice and
more people were drifting as they finish
up on their their coffee and the like so
in this product talk of want to just
focus on the undie f-sharp is sort of
developed a specialty i think in
features which are heavily inspired by
academic research or which are outright
contributions as research papers but
which also are carefully chosen to be to
be to solve a set of industry critical
problems and to sort of enhance the
power of of the functional of the core
functional programming paradigm and one
way one way i like to summarize this
strand of work is as f sharp as a
research project is to take a
retrospective from 1998 through to today
and think how programming has changed
particularly I mean from F sharp
particularly like HR perspective like
what I feel we've been able to
completely change the way that Microsoft
approaches languages and software
development now this is partly to
danette the.net framework the partly to
do with language were coming from
Microsoft researching in Cambridge as
well and so we have to take our mind
back to 1998 and everything that was in
vogue back in 1998 all kind of remember
the various days of smoking ban in
california for the xml was all the rage
and object-oriented programming in java
was all the rage objects objects objects
rule the world java2me was a great
language as a great meme you've plugged
into the meme of the internet very well
but somehow what i loved about
programming was completely missing and
mark if we looked at microsoft back then
and microsoft research mark self was
touting things like the digital
dashboard or something which nobody ever
quite knew what it was and that
was that the best we could do with
regard to innovation and on functional
programming it really was a bit of a
ghetto we would experience if functional
programming has been great when using
systems like a camel but we couldn't
make them work in real there's a great
paper by Phil waddle about know why no
one uses functional languages about the
isolation its nature of functional
languages and that's from 1997 that was
heavily influenced the design directions
of F sharp and now if we roll forward
and we think just about this this part
of the programming world net f sharp C
sharp visual basic and so no there's
been great advances in lots of other
practical programming languages in the
theory of languages as well but we see
things like dotnet generics are just
completely changing the foundations on
which we build object-oriented
programming and this had this it also
enables F sharp which built all the way
through on.net generics then we see
things like c-sharp link which is I mean
is still just an amazing achievement
that we have a declarative query
language integrated query programming in
a major industrial language there'll be
many other languages will be playing
catch-up with that for a long time we
have things like the F sharp
metaprogramming we have units of measure
in f-sharp we have the integration of
task-based silk-like task based
programming through dotnet four-point-oh
we have the integration of asynchronous
and parallel programming and F sharp we
see that directly being taken by C sharp
and visual basic so suddenly we're going
from the position where generics took
what generics took 30 years to get into
practice from clue through to through to
c sharp and I mean those various
manifestations along the way but I think
we really sealed it in c-sharp and we're
seeing a much faster turnaround units of
measure to
from 1994 for the core in the call work
on the the inference algorithm used by
the F sharp units of measure it was
1994-97 and we turned that around in ten
years to be in in in in in in in a
professional programming language and in
the c-sharp vivir asynchronous parallel
work well in some ways that's a form of
continuation based programming or state
machine based programming or Co routine
programming which has been around for a
long time but the latest manifestation
of that is definitely now entering the
the mainstream family of languages and
along the way I hope we've been able to
do this with an eye on transferable
research results that you see the
publications in in PL di or the
publication forms like the C sharp
specification and standardization of
those or we see publications around c
sharp link or about a synchronous and
parallel programming and and units of
measure so and so on so that these
aren't just practical results were
actually transferable research
contributions that can be picked up by
other languages as well they're my
favorite papers among all of those ones
so to me we have changed programming in
practice and opened up a route between
academia and industry I think we've
proven that there's a lot more to typed
programming than the core java model
when you think about all these different
results they would have all been
incredibly controversial according to
the object-oriented orthodoxy of the the
late 1990s and which I think really
proven that the object-oriented
orthodoxy is not the right way to tackle
the problems of query based programming
of strongly typed programming with
generics of asynchronous and parallel
and agent based programming and that the
core type systems can be augmented by
refinements like units of measure so
there's much we place Microsoft Research
at the heart of language innovation at
Microsoft and the industry more
generally and functional programming
is now viable and really just entirely a
part of mainstream programming half of C
sharp programmers would also consider
themselves functional programmers gives
you thousands and thousands and
thousands of functional programmers in
in using functional programming all the
time in the real world in their
day-to-day work and I think we've gone
beyond those core language issues to be
talking about data access and parallel
programming and in these language
integrated queries and asynchronous
programming okay so let's talk about the
F sharp asynchronous programming model
i'm going to hand over to thomas to to
give his view of this but if you want to
know the paper to teach captures this
model it's a pro from panel 2011 if you
do search for the title or the author's
or paddle 2011 you'll you'll get it off
my of our various papers and just if
you're interested in units of measure
this is the paper for that one of the
many papers by andrew kennedy there's a
lot of very interesting theory about
units of measure about the inference
algorithm that's used in f-sharp about
the what it means for units to be to go
wrong at runtime and so this is sort of
a semantics semantics view of units of
measure so over to thomas foot just to
talk about asynchronous programming
I'll turn my mic off this time
okay does it work fine yeah so I won't
have as much time as I expected so I'll
skip some of the some of the topics i'll
start by by introducing asynchronous
programming Kenneth sharp so I'll show
you some of the basic examples then I'll
talk a little bit about some
asynchronous programming patterns that
people have been using in a sharp that
the F sharp library library provides
I'll say a few words about how f sharp
async relates to the recently-announced
extension to see charm for asynchronous
programming and I'll talk very briefly
about my research extension of the
programming mobile which is not going to
be in any version of F sharp anytime
soon unless them changes his mind but
it's available as a extension for the
open source version of F sharp and I'll
arm it's it's it extends the programming
Mobile in I believe quite interesting
way and it also demonstrates that you
can use F sharp to do research in
functional programming languages so the
problem of asynchronous programming is
really based on programming with
callbacks there are many operating
system functions that you can invoke our
asynchronously meaning that you give the
function some some callback for example
minh reading contents of a file you give
the function some callback and the
function will call the the operation
will call your call back when it
completes because the operation takes a
long time to run it may need to wait for
the disc or it may need to wait for the
network and it doesn't do anything in
the meantime so you want to avoid
blocking the current threat that execute
the operation at least on on systems
like that and JVM
we're treads are quite expensive so it
supports it's the main purpose is to
support io bound operations in a real
reliable scalable way where you can
spawn thousands of tasks or some agents
and they can all run in parallel without
blocking the threat when they don't need
to and it's it's quite serious and
relevant industry problem yes I'll say a
few things about that arm it's not based
directly on the.net task DPL mole
because it existed before the doctor TPL
mobile and it's mainly it's also it also
allows you allows us to do some things
that aren't directly supported by the
TPL mobile but you could define an
alternative implementation based on the
TPL oh it wouldn't give you all the
benefits that easily mainly maybe but
i'll say a few things about the
comparison because the c-sharp version
of this is using the.net ppl model and
so I'll compared it to a little bit so
this is just a brief example of some
explicit event-based our programming
style where we are creating the callback
explicitly so we're um it's it's
something you could you could brighten a
sharp so we are starting some HTTP
server and if we specify a function that
should be called whenever a request
comes when a request comes we start some
download from some proxy URL and when
the download completes it would call our
function and we would we would write the
data that we received to the output to
the response stream and it would give us
some
are we would specify a callback that
should be called when the operation
completes ah and then close the stream
so this solves part of the problem it's
concurrent programming mole we are not
blocking the threat ah and this this
programming style I use this as an
example because it's becoming quite
popular there's a library called nodejs
which implements essentially this in in
javascript but the syntax isn't you have
to ride the callbacks explicitly so
really we would like to write something
like this we are just doing three calls
in in sequence we download some data
ride the data to the output close the
output stream maybe in f-sharp we should
really probably write something like
this we should make sure that the stream
is closed even if some exception of
yours and writing these kind of things
in the explicit explicit programming
model is really difficult and using
f-sharp asynchronous workflows we can
write it like this so the AC the thing
is that we edit this async block which
wraps the whole code and it essentially
means that the inner code should be
translated to some continuation passing
style and we are using these bank
operations to dunno to specify where the
operation should be done asynchronously
using call back and so the only language
syntax extension is the async block and
these two bank keywords otherwise on the
inside we can reuse use although all the
syntax or most of the syntax of F sharp
I like try finally and it gets
translated to some operations that are
provided by the async async object so
the translated code
how it compiles that looks roughly like
this so the bind operation corresponds
to the lead bank keyword where are we
are taking the asynchronous operation
and some continuation that should be
called when the operation completes
nested bindings are is translated to
message nested function calls there are
some additional operations like a single
0 which is our operation that doesn't
return anything and there's also a tri
finally operation which is something
that the library provides and it
implements something like continuation
based try finally try finally construct
so this takes some asynchronous
operation these three lines and a
function that should be called are at
the in the in the finally block and this
operation takes care of making sure that
when there's some tailor in this block
it will call the it will catch the
exception and run days or if there's no
no exception it will run the
finalization anyway yes the icing zero
there are that's because I'm not
returning any result from the function
so the function just as some imperative
reading and an imperative writing if I
wanted to return some result i would i
would use return for example some number
and the 0 creates some asynchronous
operation that returns unit so it's just
on in this case it means the same thing
as return unit value but in other
computation types it could mean
different things yes
the question is whether the lead bank
operator means anything outside of the
acing block no the bank operators can
live only inside the inside some blocks
that provide the bind operation to
specify the meaning of it but it's it so
the lead bank outside of async would
probably mean the same thing as usual
lat ah if you would interpret it as a
sum identity moment or or something like
that the reason why there's led bank and
let in the syntax is that you can also
use a usual left keyword to bind value
to some expression that's not a
synchronous in this case or that's not
monadic in in general case so that's the
that's the translation are to say a few
things about some some asynchronous
programming one that you can are these
are these are some patterns that you can
implement using the basic asynchronous
workflow machinery that f-sharp provides
so there are the first two are just
supported by some Combinator's in the
library to implement furniture in
parallel ism you can use a single
parallel which takes a list of async
operations and gives you amazing
cooperation that returns list of all the
results and that can be used to spawn
multiple parallel workflows and wait
until all of them complete to implement
futures you can you can there's there's
some operation that starts workflow and
gives you some token back and then you
can wait then you can do some other
things on the main logical threat and
eventually at some point wait until the
background operation completes
so that's all supported by the F sharp
library there's also a library for
writing airlink style agents where which
also relies on the asynchronous
programming bubble so an agent is is
some object that executes some body
which is asynchronous workflow and the
body repeatedly waits for messages when
the agent receives a message it can
react in some way by sending some
messages to other agents and so on the
main the main reason why this is built
on top of F sharp asynchronous workflows
is that if we make the body asynchronous
we can wait for messages without
blocking the current threat so you can
create thousands tens of thousands of
agents that all run on are a few threats
in the in the dotnet thread pool or in
the extreme case it can all run on a on
a single thread which is relevant for
for the last async pattern if you are
creating some user interface interaction
code then typically the user interface
doesn't do any heavy calculations it
just changes some some label of a button
or something like that and are in many
libraries are definitely on dotnet and I
think it applies to other frameworks as
well you can only access user interface
elements from from the main single
threat so in f-sharp you can also use
asynchronous workflows if you execute
them in some special way to write
reactive applications that run on single
thread and interleaf steps of several
asynchronous workflows when they are
blocked by waiting for an event or
something like that so I'll our show you
one example of using the reactive
programming mobile
in.net in general there is an interface
called I observable that represents
events and you can be you that you can
be you this as a semantically as a list
of time value pairs so it's are some
data some structure that are represents
events that can occur repeatedly like
mouse clicks and when the event happens
are it gives you some value like the X&Y
coordinates and do access this this data
structure from the F sharp asynchronous
programming mobile we can use evade
observable which takes the observable
event representation and it gives us a
synchronous workflow that waits for the
first event that for the first
occurrence after the time when we call
this our call this operation so it's not
it's not semantically pure it has a side
effect in a sense that it realized on
the current time and we can use this
operation to write something like the
code below hopefully you can ah I'll
move it like this so this is an example
are where we are creating a synchronous
workflow that waits for the first
occurrence of some click event and it
gives us coordinates of the of the click
our event occurrence and we can call we
can use this this operation repeatedly
which is one interesting aspect of F
sharp this creates just some function
that we can start repeatedly and it will
it will execute the body multiple times
are and we can call we can use this
function recursively to wait for the
next event and so on so
example I'll I'll write that will
hopefully give this some sense is a
semaphore light which is a fairly simple
idea the idea is that we want to create
some application where you will click on
the on the screen or on some button and
as you click it will loop through all
the semaphore states and the usual
imperative approach that people use at
least in c-sharp Java is that because
this is this is reactive you cannot
really encode it in some natural way so
the way people would write it is to have
some mutable state and when you click
the handler would change the mutable
state and modify the user interface but
in that in that way you don't really see
what the transitions between the states
are so a better approach would be to
write some loop that simply loops
through all the states ah and that can
be done using the asynchronous
programming model in f-sharp so this is
a sample application which is using
silverlight which means that it runs
inside a browser as a component but
that's really just the aspect of the
sample the main part is is this which
are is some asynchronous computation
that waits for mouse click then displays
the green light then waits for the next
mouse click displays the orange light
and so on so if i run the example it
starts with all the lights turned on and
if i click it runs through the
asynchronous workflow and i just
explicitly road waiting for three events
so i cannot wait for if i click it the
workflow ends after the three clicks so
that's why it ended up
red light but I can use all the F sharp
syntax inside the workflow so if i
change it by by adding while too i will
hopefully get a semaphore light which
loops through all the all the colors so
it's really the code I'm writing is more
like long-running asynchronous operation
that encodes some aspect of the
interaction it encodes some state
machine that the user can that the
programmer can easily draw and
understand and I can make this code
sample even nicer by using a simple for
loop that iterates over list of states
so the same loop can be encoded like
this by having a for loop that iterates
over the three colors and wrap this
inside by luda for the whole time the
application is running iterate so lets
me do the due to perform the interaction
so i think that's that's quite elegant
way people can use to express bonk
running operations or interactions with
the user interface this programming
style as i think very imperative nature
in a sense that you're waiting for
events and reacting by changing some
some estate in the application it can be
made a nicer by writing some higher
higher level Combinator's over this this
programming style but that's that's
another question and i'll maybe start
talking about the research extension
that i worked on yes yep
ah yes so in this case I'm not returning
anything because the loop is its
infinite loop I have wild true so the
loop is our is infinite but it's
asynchronous so it doesn't block the
application it yes it it runs in
background forever and it never returns
anything
very
I guess this is this is valuable because
you can separate concurrent programming
from parallel programming where
concurrent means are just running
multiple logical threats are using some
interleaving or cooperative cooperative
multitasking each time the application
blocks in blood bank asynchronous
operation the thread is it just stores
the operation on some stack or something
and the threat is the single threat of
the of the user interface is free to do
other processing there was some other
question yes
yes so that I think you can compare this
style with the declarative style that
don't demonstrate it when doing the
Twitter example where you used things
like event map event dot filter and
that's that's more the declarative or
FRP like functional reactive programming
like style of describing the interaction
the reason why I think this is this is
useful is that expressing arbitrary
state machine in the using the
Combinator style is a bit difficult or
at least I haven't found a nice way to
do it and this this programming style
allows you to draw the state machine on
the paper and just directly encode that
idea in your program and the reason why
I wanted to move to the research
extension is that it was something
that's motivated directly by the
previous example if your encoding a
state machine you can use sled bank to
wait for one event but very often you
want to have a choice between two events
or you want to wait for some combination
of events or for an event that carries
some particular value and that's
something you cannot quite directly
Express with the current language
current syntax of asynchronous workflows
so there are there are quite a few other
examples aside from event based
programming some tasks when programming
with futures like wait for both features
or wait for the first one that returns
through or something like that or even a
programming mobile based on joint
calculus that's something that's very
well known in theory it works very well
but it's it's difficult to implement
that in in practice and
the extension I did for F sharp as this
match Bank construct which is are just
like lead bank is a general is a
asynchronous version of let this is
asynchronous version of of pattern
matching so the arguments here are some
some computations or some special bodies
in this example they will be futures and
if you write this example it will start
the futures in in parallel and then when
both of them complete you'll eventually
run this this block of code because the
syntax we can use inside the patterns is
either bank and some pattern which means
wait for a value that matches this
pattern or you can use you can use
underscore which means we don't really
need the operation to complete we don't
care if it gives us a value or not so in
this example they sing codes waiting for
two futures ah with a special case when
one of the futures returns zero because
then we can return the result
immediately without waiting for the
other future so that this case is the
general case that will be used when both
features complete and give us some value
this case these two cases are special
cases when one of the one or the other
future completes producing zero and the
other we don't know yet if it if it
completed or what value we got yes
ah well they are also prioritized by
order so if in this case it does it
doesn't really matter but if you have
two cases with a bank a bank be it would
select the first one by definition in
this case the only possible overlap is
if the two futures completed at the same
time which is a non-deterministic non
deterministic waiting so that's a bit
tricky question if we had deterministic
programming mole they probably wouldn't
be able to complete at the same time so
if if it would if it would be possible
for both of them to complete at the same
time and one returns 0 then it would
still run the first Clause because it
checks the closest in order yep so the
way this example would run is that are
when the mage bank expression arm runs
it starts both computations when one of
them produces value it will check if it
can run any of the clauses are if the
value is 0 then it would immediately run
the body and cancel the other future and
the same thing can be can be used to
encode our programming level based on
join calculus where we are in the
previous case the future produced only
one value at after some time the joint
case is it's quite different because we
are matching on some channels that can
have values repeatedly and the idea is
that if there's if there's some claws
that can be executed using the values
that are currently in the channel then
it will run the round the claws so if we
have a combination of put int which is
this close
and brained print message then it will
run the body but if there are multiple
values in the channel they stay in the
in the channel so um I won't go into
details are you can find more if you
search for joy Nets there's a there's a
battle battle paper ah and the idea is
that we try to find some abstract
description or in terms of operations
like bind that you can use to match all
these all these different programming
models together so dumb do you want to
go or should I say a few things about C
sharp so the there are quite a few few
design choices that have to be made when
when designing this asynchronous
programming model are I think there are
two main differences between how this is
done in f-sharp and how this will
probably be done in the next version of
C sharp the F sharp language uses
reusable syntax extension so in the in
some of the examples I was using our i
used some other block instead of async i
use future or join and gave the parent
meaning to the special operations inside
inside the block in the c-sharp proposal
they have just a particular syntax for
asynchronous programming in the style of
the async workflows in f-sharp the
benefit of the c-sharp approach is that
they can easily have more optimized
compilation data inside the code to some
state machine which requires less
allocations than continuation based
approach in a sharp on the other hand in
f-sharp because it's in library it's
much easier to support more feet more
few more features
for example F sharp has implicit support
for cancellation of asynchronous work
clothes which isn't done in in c-sharp
probably because they would have to
implement it inside the compiler and not
just as a library feature and also the
reusable syntax is it allows us to do
many other things beyond just
asynchronous programming which is I
think very very valuable and the other
difference is that there are quite a few
ways of representing asynchronous
operations the the categorization that
people inside Microsoft use our i'm not
sure if it has any any better names from
research background but if you have cold
task it means that the asynchronous
workflow are creates some object a task
that can be started and will eventually
give you a value on either using some
continuation or by blocking the hot task
programming hole that will be probably
used in in c-sharp returns a task that's
already running so if you if you write
async something something then it
creates a task and starts the task and
the f-sharp programming model is based
on continuations so essentially it's
it's a function that you can call with
the continuation it will start doing
something and eventually call the
continuation are the main difference is
that you can use the same asynchronous
workflow run it multiple times ah and I
I believe this this programming model
better matches the compositional
functional style because just creating a
synchronous workflow doesn't actually
run any any operations so there are
quite a few cases where
are the other programming homeless would
be a bit confusing for F sharp but
that's that's essentially the difference
or the choices that you have when
designing feature like this and I'll
hand over to them
ok so we're running through these four
pitches in this party actually we've
done now we'll be talking about
measuring that measurement is what I
think of data inches shafted Winona
three-pointer and so here's a measure a
chapel east side slides from bedroom
kandi still talks on this could've added
them online and there's a great series
of tutorial notes I think in some
measure is dis is a beautiful theory
practice feature which Andrews tutorial
notes from the summer school last year
major European currencies that he was
excellent set of notes to start with
just like a practical physics
programming you know doing kilogram
meters acceleration things that students
are made a million but then by the end
of talking about relational semantics or
four units and really beautiful and
practice
a single topic and the topic is just
slightly off to the side in the sense is
not like you don't get up in language
arguments that much about yo is is once
in sharp they're better than F sharp or
any other things that is focusing on on
his 11 topic as you okay so the only
practical side that is great examples of
some NASA experiment related where
they're firing lasers up space shuttle
and then inspect shuttle did this
instead of trying to point itself to
once the mountain and they all wondered
why they were going upside down and
turns out that they thought the mountain
north and Falcon nautical miles above
sea level and 10,000 feet above sea
level so that was programmed correctly
and to the whole special setting up the
wrong way there's also some more
catastrophic version for the same thing
went wrong because it makes up for in
English Felix monkey Mountain News
English units of measure while the
agency's metric 13 space
very badly wrong ok so we salute has
been such an obvious solution subject
units of development time but static
analysis or by five chicken and it has
this is not a new observation long
history of the mixture of language idea
there's like what's bus library for
so I mean there's two sides to what
Android design in a sharp first of all
it's actually put into practice you know
the way really not interested in the
language we really just start to use
units in a very natural way just when
you need to take a floating-point
numbers are just start to annotate them
in kilograms and so on and a key thing
is that and I think why it's so
interesting from the ml and the language
perspectives is it fits beautifully with
type inference ending normal type
inference there are very few theories
algebraic theorems which which have
given best solutions in the moment I
preference I think units of measure is
one of the theories that does have a
beauty best solutions and a lot of n
newspapers are about describing why that
type of sense works in practice and what
this means you can not only write
concrete unitized code where you're
getting a concrete ground innocent
magical granted leaders and so on
because you can also write generic
unitized code and the type inference
which is kick in and make the code
automatically generic once you want to
indicate
intense to go on in a couple of places
and that is actually important in
practice if people are writing that
common mistake is in a basic statistical
algorithms to make some variance and
standard deviation Sigma and Sigma
squared and you can see that in the unit
analysis and generic unit analysis of a
generic statistical algorithm and we
found the core mistakes and core
statistical code then deployed Microsoft
algorithms talk about a case study
within a moment based just on better
inference over the unit are over the
code measure so the design here's yes
and minimally invasive with typing
friends in the spirit of ml and Haskell
in a normal type inference we start
annotating literals with units and in
some inference to the rest and we really
didn't get that feeling where you take
these programs so is one example I
worked on a simulation code standard
gravitational simulation code and it's
just a sea of floating point numbers
right and you go yeah and without using
to measure you start to use various
techniques to control the complexity of
just like everything's a number and then
you start using units of measure and
suddenly you're distinguishing
astronomical units from meters and your
description simmering seconds in
simulation time from seconds in real
time and suddenly all the distinctions
become clear and the sea and you're
really working with numbers
a different level of confidence in your
home so and it really is the matter you
just annotate some of your ground inputs
right so your your your your constants
for gravity or your law
so this is the have some conversion
factors to be converted the national
team units and so on and they have some
second thing yeah but everything was
just a floating point number that's an
opportunity not puncturing the
conversion real parts and model time
that is just a 24 numbers are floating
point number there's a lot of scope to
mistake in this color get done without
description of a planet simulation code
and there's plenty of plenty of scope
from the states here you know forget the
square of arable beer in a hurry so much
so let's take a look at the unitized
version
ok
that's a simple
this agreement and a 3d fantasy 3d
version of this with proper texture and
the life would I drew cannot imagine
looking like that yeah this is actually
one of the domestic around in the trash
outside being sober driver weight
against another but now let's look at
the code when we had viewed as a measure
so first of all we have we define our
basic majesty
milliseconds for the Rams kilometres and
now when we second squared and the
conversion factors between natural units
just happen that you guys that we
would expect astronomically do you know
we could start to have a use for screen
for women's like pixels so what scaling
reebok now we know with strong
confidence while scaling that simulation
on the right is using 200 pixels one
astronomical unit and become know that
by Proclamation this concert here in
code that is going to be tight check and
we're not making very very unlikely to
making these things about that
conversion now when we have seconds per
year it becomes a float of seconds
because when you multiply is out
sort of annotating a ground constant as
well and now where we have a function to
convert in real time to model time
there's a difference between seconds in
real time in seconds in in model time ok
so now when we have our code the input
variable here now is a potent number
astronomical so now we know what that
number was ever I'm not going to make a
mistake for mistake now when we deal
with out the code here let's say we make
them safe and the squaring factor here
and get an error saying straightaways
meter squared and thanks to staying all
the way through immediately giving us
this strong talking over the phone and
then the rest of the courage salespeople
much exactly the same we get down to the
Wikipedia constants
we start to multiply things up so if you
take data from the Pegasus when I got it
off Wikipedia was in kilometres so
conveniently just quite a conversion
factor to get back an astronomical units
and that there are no examples of
generic infants in this cone but
okay so I think I kids are feeling four
units of measure the key thing is that
there's no runtime cost that's all
arrays that means their numbers remain
numbers with no implicit allocations and
which just means so that you can have
confidence about performance
characteristics of a floating-point code
is extensible we can use it for all
sorts of numeric types musica vectors
and matrices and so on technically
there's no support the dimensions the
notional mass for example and there's no
support for automatic conversions I've
been seeing how you define the explicit
conversion to get from one to the other
but actually you can do automatic
conversions in this kind of system but
the problem is is a lot of choices about
where the compiler answers the
conversion to the inside of the leaves
are inserted resources and since
floating point numbers I triple is like
my numbers are not perfectly scalable
they don't really want to hide those
kind of choices from the programmer so I
think it's a wise practical decision not
to put in conversions
and to say you can use this in other
domains of people use it in pretty much
any numerical analysis code this is sort
of fundamental kind of example generally
for finance because the quantities are
scalable and there's a lot of
exponentiation but we don't get the same
I don't get a good innovation then using
selling abstract notion commanding a
shame you don't volume in things down
but they like you can choose this sort
of granularity naturally literally tape
about not going to try to over use the
future Oh Andrew I saw this quote from
andrea i imagine doing this one covers
on from bill gates that's why he never
answered
this is well we were done
no this system so there's a whole is all
these classes refining the time systems
which might feel very similar when added
to the language and and but plan to that
particular refined it you can't just
have a general motion of account
attached to this to integer quantities
as well which does the scale but you
can't sell our general refinement system
by attaching credits that's much more
interpretive I f7 which says research
ascension of F sharp something like
simply subscribe refinement types and
part of the peloton rattle off at my
mother pretending to be a fireman
I mean I do think these refinement uh
systems are like just gradually going
I mean it's especially an area where
languages like a chaplain very heavy on
offense and very good have been the main
focus languages have a goal by if you
try to do this measure in chocolate
about fashion
so so no we erase all the information
there are various ways you can choose
alternative motive for matalan cables
sygic are to perfection when you do
reflection of their type of these things
we want only things will disappear so it
is a static feature you could imagine I
mean from a research perspective I think
definitely imagine taking the virtual
machine designs take the mono
presentation runtime for example and
push in some measure through the runtime
type information that gets stored and
put you have to be careful to put in the
algebra so that we this time seconds is
the same a second time two meters right
so to make sure all the bow be there is
no one to the type performing and then
you can do that laughing I actually
think doing in.net generics we did this
like an extension of language and
runtime pushing into targets may go all
the way to learn is very very good
results I think what we should be doing
more of that in the research community
and mono is I think a great place you're
doing those experiments because they
already have type situation
generics so it's a matter because
extending that part and I get the pits
and students during those time and
produce there's been something just I
found a bit depressing about the last 15
years since the day Liam came along that
we haven't had students going and really
modifying a virtual machine like as much
as we should have everyone's been trying
to work as if these virtual machines
were said in modifying
are in the static by L F sharp stores an
extra metadata month off to the side XL
we're containing more type information
which it folds together with the io f
sharp F sharp code understands innocent
measure when you look at it from C sharp
all the innocent numbers
okay so let's take a look at up on a
shop to point out
so in this section I I want to just run
through some case studies to do a
feeling for why an f-sharp we're so
interested in the problems of of data of
programming which data part this because
when we look at what I shoppers Paul we
talked about problem solving from the
language level but in terms of a
business Microsoft we really see that
f-sharp has a mesh role in aero data
rich analytical engines okay we're not
thinking that sharp of the new interface
programming language we just really
focus on this core data processing data
and there's something about functional
programming is so fantastically did this
isolationist tendency of functional
programming means the most functional
languages don't work in a daily rich
environment so we have Haskell it's
relatively rare you're bringing data in
from the outside and if it is it's a
little painful together this for my data
some extent that's true and camel as
well and but F sharp of course it hasn't
got that libraries you suddenly as a CEO
stronger type data through into the
language and that lets once you have
this storage of data that really thats
time for programming sort of like when
what has amazing processing and
transforming that data and when we think
about that we don't just mean running
well we mean you might have these
engines running out on the client on a
Windows machine on server-side
programming in particular but you can
also imagine having these running and
component or in the cloud on Amazon or
as your rv's on xbox as well and we have
examples of all of these let me see
there's a game called carpet code and
part that goes all about cut using a
pattern matching of a large machine
between encode data sets and using
machine learning to decide the position
of the next move in the go games and
that's on the runs on the Xbox sector
but also will also be running on the
phone I'm not an example of f happened
using the server and also be used to run
similar engines in the cloud the same
engine might end up running in all of
these different places so just running
through the first of these examples is
to say why we why this is the domain of
use of F sharp and why David is so
important and so this is the company
called neon Powergen I want the biggest
energy providers in Europe there they
run our an engine to balance the
national power generation
Michelle Benjamin dressed in an
application might be in the scene shop
uses units of measure everywhere which
is interesting and spent time and wrote
up this case study he said they get a
really cool thing role of that child
addresses complexities are hardly of the
application is an algorithmic analysis
of large data sets and that when you
drew out why f sharp important for that
kind of problem at the sting operation
you need to measure to an interesting
that you mention ninety five centimeter
programmers never touch them but when
they are needed they are critical as in
the simulation frame and then he went
through this explosion programming
encoded up and it's very very very
clearly summary and wife jump a white
punctual type cultural programming is so
effective the practice for this funding
this kind of today so there's lots of
example finance companies are doing a
very similar thing about enhanced rating
engines risk analysis engines work the
other day sets during efficient
algorithmic analysis of both datasets
biotech there are good examples of well
as well just building DNA processing
engine and it's being really does matter
twenty two hundred times faster than
pipe image of a lot of people use for
this kind of work today and the last
case study of a look at is this use of F
sharp for the machine learning algorithm
is hard for bings click prediction for
ads its particles that sheer scale of
the data is enormous in this case they
face in real time updates
Morgan fees per second that says people
choose whether to click on an ad or they
enter search terms and but yeah every
time someone's picking on that he's been
displayed to this service which is
awfully random peeps and so I've had a
little delivery research in the United
States and there is a competition around
at Microsoft we're learning over 60
revive Tony dataset game is that the
teams had four weeks of working with the
data and in this case now for machine
learning experts and lots of research
and they are not writing an application
and purple the significance application
which is basically a factor graph of 100
future rated shoot sets of arrays of 100
million publicity as a publicity
variables representing the knowledge or
various parts of like what is someone's
maybe the IP arrest or what is there
what is it what search words were in the
terms of their queries and I've been
entering of the characteristics of the
ads that they had aspired to make a
choice to click on or not click on and
in the end that kind of information is
totally critical for deciding what ads
actually displayed in the boxes and very
very direct correspondence to revenue
and pricing for the ads in Google and
works in 36 * bytes of data took them
two weeks to see if any time to train up
their model and they also wanted to be
real time learning so you could adjust
the whole the whole inference algorithm
in real time as such changes over time
of the web and F sharp really was that
they won the competition bettina
cambridge i also want it in an
interesting way that they had
immediately deployable code it wasn't a
message service process and other teams
had the day actual code was extremely
ready to written to go in the various
reasons of things in America and other
12 months before actually deployed its
organizational things and all yeah watch
this team as they were doing it and the
type inference was just just really
important they what to think in their
domain they could refactor the code and
parameterizing in very nice ways they
could be scripting and explore the data
sets they could scale to very very large
data sets publicist floating-point
AmeriCorps F and F sharp is very memory
faithful so when I say memory faithful
is that dot net has his facility called
struct so when you create arrays
instruction you know you're not getting
garbage collection you're getting a
concrete data structure a
back-of-the-envelope calculations about
how much how many of these variables you
can fit in a 16 gigabyte machine and
that really is kind of critical than
kind of trust your execution environment
to be allocating objects with especially
the large data structure and there's a
sickness was that they as they're really
doing formed probabilistic programming
publicity engineering and they got to
really live in that domain rather than
think about the all the object or the
kind of stuff that I've been showing
before they did use the symbolic
programming okay so the thing there you
can see that f-sharp is developing a
sort of anish specialty datacard area
well
this is an extreme one I put the sound
on until some funky music invented it
goes a little bit too fast so let me
just put Lisa Looney Tunes cartoon music
watching it then some all-night some
questionable forward this is a fun way
of answering the question so he's a nut
shop programmer function test that
returns this and two numbers there for
the tuple basically yeah this is a chose
the translation of that to see sharper
than running it through this FX pop tool
to the quality engineering 42 tells you
to adjust your sin shop codeine in
various ways so the program I kind of
starts with this
okay so this is sort of stuff you have
to write and send everybody don't
structure here and then you have a test
function and we graduate AG point and
you killing those little pieces to add
comparative add to those collections and
then you turn right and then you start
running it through the quality tool okay
and tells you things like well you've
got to scrub to you okay let's talk
about how you ride Scott and you should
override equals methods and you should
be giving a quality just in case anybody
ever wants to do a quality yo get is
struck time right so the car ground on
Natalie you know they're sitting you're
automatically they get richburg laser
blue squares or something oh yes oh stop
hurting yourself opportunity and you
feel like it getting work done because
she was telling you actually do this
work that's it goes on so that you do
that and then they get this strap top
gun explodes out and
may I get there and say well I came into
pieces after the internal it's a bit
wobbly I'll protect it and I'm going to
continue on ok let's do all about my
product it's going to go look up a book
about how to implement a hash code
operator combine hash codes and
incorrectly casing they don't like the
lowercase things here and then provide
more meaningful names an x and y for
these names familiar ones many
formations and then check play over
so now that's extreme that was 35 lines
or something and a programmer would
probably choose because I'm getting
something so simple done choose not to
go down that car 11 to c virus returns
or some other feature for encoding for
eternity to point that you can I be the
factor in practice the different effect
or different sense without affecting two
or three sides and but it doesn't
necessarily translate to two or three
times improvement readability but Roland
Michell code will be just as readable
territorial differences depending on the
demand
yeah I mean in that domain I think often
anymore two or three is the minimum when
you change like
but no one's done a homicidal death upon
us ideas it's quite feasible
prosthetists like to like know each
other everything else is introduced the
language of people okay so in the last
time we talked we look at taste of what
we're doing in a shopkeeper no now I'm
going to be going through this material
in full in the session on Thursday and
but in a sense what we're doing here is
very very simple and very simple
rationality we experience the world's
been information-rich all the time we
experience that on the computer in the
web and also to other places all the
time and modern applications are totally
driven by these by structured data
sources repeated every noise every
applicant internet connection connected
application alone there's no data on the
phone although all the data is coming
from some external cloud-based web based
source of data and applications there's
a sense in which applications like word
are also information rich but he's a
very general notion of information is a
spreadsheet or document or something but
applications today much more tied to
particular information sources and are
about mashing up data sources for for
for example these invisible today so but
of course we know that our languages and
libraries and frameworks incredible
information sparse who can't find a
definition of a chemical element the
definition of a football player the
definition of a bridge we don't make
framework nor in the scene shop language
specification for those are the terms
which people office
work program and so we want to address
this person it is actually a problem
it's a very big problem for this
strongly typed languages because you're
always working fifty percent I reckon
when I go visit customers using see
sharpener sharpen factors fifty percent
of their code is about mediating between
external data sources and strongly typed
world that they want to be working it
and so sooner or later people end up
giving up on these from the top language
isn't moving the JavaScript and we fight
them and move to other languages where
they just don't have types to get in the
way when they just kind of they never
need to think about getting things into
astronomy platform and so they throw the
baby out with the bathwater and just
start working we know you know is the
type way so f sharp three-pointed i was
very much about investing this
problematic or architectural level in
the language and we do not by adding a
kinship called high prevalence so think
about it if you if you need to come up
with a strongly-typed do many of your
favorite strongly typed languages and it
needs to come up with them the chemical
elements strongly type how long would
that take you to design that library and
to populate that largely good
information and the documentation might
be part of a chemistry application maybe
a contractor and the new believe you can
actually paid to do this this work and
so what i want to give you a taste of is
the application of this F sharp 3d point
O type provider future to getting
language integration strongly typed
moment integration of a web ontology in
this case so we're going to use a
semantic web ontology called freebase
and you can think of it as sort of
strongly typed Wikipedians lot of
information is taken by dreams during
screen scraping or Wikipedia so we're
dealing with an information source that
has thousands and thousands of curators
busy editing and improving this data set
okay so we can agree so we have our web
data and by what what what we have here
is not we're not having to have a
library 15 bucks you can't create a
library basis too many times there's
like hundreds of thousands of times on
this web ontology and then more and more
of these I'm totally without it becoming
standard practice for information
workers today and since you can't create
a library what we created instead is an
adaptive component called a park divider
which are which instead of giving a
finite set of pipes or modules functions
it gives you a computed space allows it
with a compiler to talk to this type
provider and it is effectively talking
to what is a logically a library is
actually a computer and on demand it's
like a lazily computed library or a
library less computer based on some
external data source and the key thing
is ever changing the architecture left
our tools of
interactive development environment
including the SF incorrectly and
including the command line compiler that
you can use be able to accept these type
providers to allow you to plug a sharp
into some external lights cute eyes data
sources so let's take a look what that
gives us as we now work with this
ontology we now have a direct line
connection with this witness on quality
where we can use the elements objects
types to finding that on top of you
directly in a strongly typed way we've
done full language integration of the
external data sources into a type of
functional programming language so our
job was to find the chemical elements
from attack so there are the chemical
elements
so while that's loading up
SuperBass for me a lot of Colombian
Mexican essentially something people
know about it this is the slowest
internet
the one of the key things is where it's
infinitely stronger type programming
again this we're getting completion we
have Parkinsons Nutella seduces a
chemical element and the properties and
knowledge about these data structures of
these multiple objects in their working
lives from the oncology available to us
in our strong target and that means
available to each other as well means we
get strong emotion gear such as health
information from from the ontology
ooh
okay so that's drawing and drawing set
of chemical elements from the from the
web data source
just to say these autologous have many
many many many interesting things in
there if there are if you're wondering
if you're mentioned it's classic they're
some of the people here mentioned
scientists genetically wrap up this
correctly then we'll eventually play
these kind of databases
so let's take a look at how you can use
this in practice so I was given the
example of my find all the asteroids
that that have to make of a great car
and what is it what is interesting is
that these things which are some ways
thought up the search problems or query
problems by the people doing
unstructured circle structured search
suddenly become a programming problems
to the software converter and suffering
to me so this took about five minutes to
do and you say okay we want to find
every asteroid that has an angle green
card well the asteroids are easy enough
to find how will the Astros under here
and we have it in some subset of this
particular data source to reach we also
have the gods so we can we start to
navigate
and then for each day while we can start
to investigate their the properties that
they have so for instance they're
looking for worship a deity and take the
religions of our support for their dad
you look at the name of the religion
here cuz there's properties about
Huggins and that's great can we leave in
the night because of the slightest
attention on the sample just continue
texture that we might that distinct my
child rudenko duplicates that's just
displaying on ever take the set of
knives we took them in dogs we have now
we start working with gas droids and
then we get down to our solution which
is great
the solution now for each asteroid
asteroid then if the woods turns out the
asteroid names contained also a number
so it's between of tweets of the Sun and
if there exists a word that intersects
with the dog set to you such a busy job
without set contains that work then we
yelled at us we're so straightforward
sort of programming approach to during a
query of a strong leap out of a
web-based information
okay so so just to say that what we're
doing as a tire provider as a compiler
at all that provides computer space of
types of methods it's a sort of Impala
or having an extension configured with
an adapter between data and services and
got that languages it's just something
you add to your project we're very small
components and they bring in even using
these talks about setting up our data
big table kind of data storage taking
sequel databases and enterprise data
local data on your machine with lots of
strongly typed Ava's actually
surprisingly popular access to web
services and you can build your own tie
providers to collecting information this
is a sort of code we would have to write
today to get the strongly type view of
the chemical elements and is a very
preliminary one which becomes a one line
one line for one moment in point so f
sharp silk contains no data but there's
an open architecture providing this
writers talk providers so I'm going to
go to this in more detail on Thursday
but the item is involves encode the
information Richmond leave our languages
and varam is an information-rich 22 when
the item is to allow pet shop to the
site great breakthrough these boundaries
between language and strongly type skin
Mkhize okay